I always I always feel weird just just
jumping into my jokes let's let's just
count in from five let's just count from
five together and then I'll go alright
here we go in five four three two one
so the other day they are they I uh
their day I saw a flyer on a telephone
pole that said did you lose a tortoise
can you imagine that level of negligence
it's like I turn my head for like two
hours
alright it's gonna be a lot of stuff
like that here we go I you know like you
know like TV shows and movies the way
they close at that person's eyes they do
that little number you know it close the
dead person's eyes I think you could use
that to get out of a conversation like
every time one of my dad's friends was
just like I stand-up comedy you make a
lot of money doing that I could be like
goodnight sweet prince
did you know you could just buy a
redwood tree yeah you can just do that
you can just go online and order a giant
sequoia I didn't know that I planted one
in my parents yard and that's a slow
burn but that's a pretty good prank it's
gonna be a real big tree
I'm skeptical if Popeye was really in
the Navy
just just cuz he calls himself the
Sailor man I don't know about that if in
real life someone came up to you and was
like I'm the Sailor man you'd be like
cool a drug addict found a hat
I read uh I read this thing that I
thought was really inspiring I thought
this was really inspirational he said I
said early on in his career dr. Seuss
was rejected by 27 publishers yeah so no
matter what happens don't ever let
anyone tell you that you have to like
dr. Seuss it's like of course it rhymes
he's making up the words no one is safe
when I come up here nobody I I don't
think I'm smart enough to have an
epiphany I don't think I could pull that
off an epiphany like Isaac Newton an
apple thawing his head and he came up
with the theory of gravity off of that
and I just would have been like oh my
god helmets for fruit we should do
helmets and fruit
good fruit helmet not enough comedians
are talking about the courtroom gavel
here we go I I think the courtroom gavel
is weirdly primitive for the situation
like if you had to explain that to
somebody you're just like a courtroom
what's that and you're like oh that's
like the thing that makes this a society
it's very official and I okay I said the
judge is holding oh that's the be quiet
hammer they still do it that way it
feels like they're figuring out what
they should do for that and a gorilla
was like you know what I would do have
you tried banging a stick on a thing so
they know you're the boss I'm uh I'm
from the Midwest sometimes I wonder if
people who grew up in like New York and
LA have like reverse Born to Run
syndrome like where do you go from there
you know so I gotta get out of this
stupid little town Los Angeles you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna move to
Indiana I'm gonna find a whole new dad
and just but grudgingly take over his
auto parts store I'm gonna live life on
my terms and their parents are like no
we wanted you to be a deejay
that's what time thank you
you